nous n'allons pas voter cette loi
d'orientation et trois formations du
ministère de l'intérieur ou pour être
plus précis nous allons voter contre
car dans l'oie d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur il y a orientation et ça
nous intéresse ça nous intéresse de
savoir quel est l'orientation donnée au
ministère de l'Intérieur pour les cinq
prochaines années d'ailleurs quand on
dit ministère de l'Intérieur il faut
considérer qu'il y a les policiers les
gendarmes mais également la sécurité
civile préfecture sous préfecture ça a
été longuement développée par le
ministre même si on a souvent cette
focale sur les questions de sécurité et
à juste titre et évidemment nous sommes
opposés à l'orientation définie par le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
ici présent mais aussi dans son annexe
de l'article premier parce que
nous avons bien vu que le compte n'y
était pas notamment sur l'aspect
programmation mais ça ça c'est mon côté
pointilleux qui cherche à savoir quel
euros sera consacré à quoi et on est un
peu en reste avec les éléments que nous
ont pourtant obtenir nous a pourtant
obtenu le rapporteur dans son amendement
détaillé j'ai voulu dire qu'il y avait
un ministre assez brillant pour obtenir
15 milliards d'euros mais pas trop quand
même pour ne pas trop savoir comment les
dépenser puisque cette question il se
les poser après peut-être un plan de
carrière 2027 étant dans le viseur et ce
qui est ce qui est tout à votre honneur
monsieur le ministre mais ce qui est un
peu dommage pour la vision que nous
devrions avoir et porté de des objectifs
à signer au ministère de l'Intérieur
monsieur bernalicis je vous avoue que je
vous reconnais pas
je sais pas ce qui vous arrive
je vous ai senti même un peu peu frustré
finalement Hugo n'était pas à Bobo Hugo
est dans l'opposition
et du coup il se répète et parfois il
confond même les discours puisque il a à
peu près parlé pendant avant-hier du
temps du discours de l'année dernière
parce que je pense qu'avec le président
de la commission des lois on se dit
tiens un jour sans fin recommencer sans
cesse recommencer monsieur Bernal ici se
reparle là c'est loi sécurité globale
pour ceux qui n'étaient pas là c'était
un moment intéressant mais je veux dire
que il faut savoir
terminer une guerre monsieur vernalis
ensuite je vous ai trouvé donc frustré
moi je n'écris madame je n'ai crié sans
personne permettait de pouvoir faire un
discours sans vous me criez dessus si
c'est possible bon
on va passer une semaine ensemble je
crois qu'on a pu passer une semaine
ensemble monsieur le député en écoutant
nos arguments je n'aime pas beaucoup
mais c'est bien normal qu'on crée mais
je pense que vous n'avez pas convocation
non plus monsieur bernaliste je l'ai
senti donc un peu frustré je vous ai
senti répétitif je vous ai senti
approximatif on en parlera dans la dans
la dans le débat je vous ai surtout
senti mauvais joueur parce que c'est
quoi une motion de rejet préalable si ce
n'est que de même pas parler des sujets
dont vous voulez qu'on parle
c'est quoi une émotion une émotion de
rejet préalable monsieur le député
bernadisse en disant tout simplement on
va même pas écouter les 15 milliards
après tout vous auriez pu dire faisons
15 milliards et on fera une
programmation budgétaire différente même
pas vous souhaitez qu'il y a pas de
débats parce que vous fuir un peu le
débat mais c'est normal que vous fiez le
débat monsieur bernaliste c'est assez
normal d'abord parce que moi je connais
votre projet de la France insoumise
c'était de désarmer la police
vous étiez vous partiez non mais vous
partiez d'un postulat d'un postulat
simple certains pourraient dire
simpliste
vous partiez d'un postuler simple que
certains pourraient dire simpliste c'est
la police-tu donc il faut désarmer la
police comme ça elle ne tuera pas c'est
sûr c'est c'est tautologie
sans doute sans doute avez-vous vu
quelques erreurs on a vu que monsieur
Mélenchon hier a même salué des
policiers donc dure le la victoire
gramsiste avance et je pense que c'est
une bonne chose peut-être qu'à la fin on
en reviendra à récompenser un remercier
les policiers voir en brasser un flic et
même des gens qui qui crachent sur les
policiers puis à la fin de leur vie de
leur vie politique de leur vie politique
de leur vie politique ils se disent mais
c'est normal on devient toujours on
devient toujours un peu conservateur à
la fin de sa vie politique et on dit bah
voilà on dit on dit à la fois à la fin
finalement c'est policiers c'était des
gens bien et comme dirait monsieur
Roussel qui qui n'est pas là peut-être
qu'il sera pas là pour voter votre
émotion de rejet c'est pas une insulte
monsieur Roussel c'est un de vos
camarades non je vous le dis parce que
comme il n'est pas là il vote avec les
pieds comme on dirait dans votre dans
votre partie il y a des ouvriers de
sécurité qu'il faut qu'il faut respecter